Hello Freak bitches post thing on my bra.
The other day I was driving, I was
thinking about news radio. You so crazy.
You mother fucking hired,
not Horshack,
but you must seen Epstein to play your
brother. Yeah, Apollo. I was just 13.
Nick Depalo and Brian Cowen. Oh my
God. Where did you pull up Epstein?
Well, they hired Epstein, but Nick Depalo
and Brian Cowen I brought in. Okay.
I thought that you hide Epstein to
yeah, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. I,
I didn't meet him until he was on the set.
He was a real nice guy though.
Did he pass away? Oh, thanks.
Yeah. Yeah. I check it.
A feeling she's good. You know, it's
really fucking sick, bro. Yeah, buddy.
The one guy you introduced me
to from that baseball show you
the Spanish guy that was on there with
you. A nice guy. Spanish guy. Yeah.
You were on a baseball show. Yeah. Well,
I'm thinking [inaudible] Willem bar.
Mike Star. Mike Star. Who, uh,
the Spanish guy that came to visit
you at the store a few times.
He's sick and guy. Yeah, I
just donated to his golf.
There's a dude from star trek.
Remember that? That dude,
it's in star trek all the time.
Uh, fucking, what is his name?
God dammit.
But he was the older picture and I
was the young asshole ballplayer.
What was that? Betty wife? Yeah, she
was not Betty. Was it Betty White? No,
the other lady from uh,
what's the cast? Some,
God damn it. I don't remember a
name. See if you can find the cast.
Yeah, but you don't want images.
No. That you want actual text.
Don't go to images. Sometimes
it pops up. Well, see?
Yeah. Ben Marie. Yeah.
Rosemary. Ben Greenwood.
Mike Star. Keep going.
Scrolling left. Yeah.
Ben Greenwood.
He thought guys in star.
He's in a bunch of movies now and
Dan Florick. He was in law and order,
but go the other way. That dude, it
only went worth, she was hilarious.
She been in a bunch of shit.
Chris Browning, he was on,
he's been a bunch of stuff recently.
Waze bike.
Fucking weird man. What
year was that? What years?
It said it was 94 four,
four.
That's when I had to move to California.
I was miserable.
I was shooting this the first couple
of days, look at me like I was like 26.
There are so weird. Um,
you know what man, when,
when it first started out
it was fun. And then, um,
what happened was with twit TV shows,
a lot of times you have like these really
funny writers and these guys who wrote
it originally were really good.
But the uh,
they had written from
married with children,
the Simpsons and the network had decided
for some reason that they weren't
strong enough to run the show and
that they, they were only writers.
They weren't like a real show runner.
So they brought in,
this guy was a show runner,
he was terrible and I didn't get along
with him at all and they were actually
close to firing me or him.
Like there was like a real like impasse
between the two of us cause the guys
riding was dog shit. I was crazy back
then. Dude, I didn't give a fuck.
I had zero filter.
I never thought it was going to
be an actor in the first place.
I couldn't believe him on the set.
And so they would try to get me to
do stuff and I'll be like, what?
And they would like give me the script.
Like,
well we made revisions to the
script and I would read that goes,
this is fucking terrible. And they would
get pissed at me and people be pissed.
I'm like, tell me how this is funny.
Explained to me how this is funny.
And then you know, like executives
are going, you know, you're either,
we're talking to my agent, this guy,
you know, he's, he's very arrogant and,
and you know, he's, he's causing
problems on the set and I'm like,
I'm not causing problems in the set.
I go, they took the writer stuff,
they rewrote it and they turned into dog
shit. You show me, show me how it's not.
And I,
and I,
I was like very close to like killing my
sitcom career completely just by having
no filter. Well then they realized
it, they read it and then they came,
has watched some of the run throughs. And
the network fired him, but it was close.
He wanted me out,
but I was one of the stars of the show.
It was me and that Ben Greenwood
Guy, but, and then, I mean it was a,
it was an ensemble show, but I
played the star player. There was,
there was about a baseball team, a
fucked up baseball team. And I was the,
the guy who was always causing trouble
and wrecking his car and going crazy.
And so they were having a real
problem with me. But it was,
it w it was because these guys
that had originally wrote it,
these guys were genius.
They were really,
really funny and they took their words
and just butchered it and turned into
something hackneyed fucked up
sitcoms. What they usually do. Well,
Jim Brewer was in the pilot with
me. Jim Brewer. That was me.
I looked like a baby. So weird. Um,
so Jim brewer was in the pilot with me.
He played the mascot for the team. Fuck.
He was funny man.
And Jim and I were buddies from New York.
There's Jim as Jim Brewer.
No,
Jim Breuer played the pioneer who,
uh,
he had like the, the bay, I feel
like, like he got in a fight,
Jeff Curran and Kevin Martin back
that up right there where you see the,
the Lens on the screen. Yeah. Where
you see the words like right there,
Kevin Curran rather than chef
Martin. Sorry, I fucked her.
Name's up Kevin Kern and Jeff
Martin with the guys who wrote it.
And um, they were really, really
nice guys and really funny guys,
but they were writers,
you know,
and this was something that they'd created
and then the network just butchered
it and then it wound up getting canceled.
And then I was ready to move back
to New York, but I fucked up.
And I had already got a
lease on an apartment.
I got an apartment on
Moore Park in studio city,
or it was actually north Hollywood.
And, uh, I was like, fuck,
I already got this apartment. Like,
what do I do? And so I'm like, God,
I gotta stay here because I've
got a lease. And I was like, shit,
I want to move back to New York.
I hated it out here.
[inaudible]
okay.